we are essentially entering a new
industrial revolution we're gonna wipe
out millions of jobs in the United
States well how far we are going to go
could easily be that everything that
really can be automated well I don't
think it would be responsible to just
let the consequences rip and then we
find that large numbers of people are
displaced and miserable and angry and
well-armed and we just figure well you
know let's see what happens we're going
to need machines that can go up and down
stairs go through hallways and doorways
handle broken concrete and just
generally go where people go
I'm at a robotics show at the forefront
of what is quickly becoming reality
like push it around can I give a shot
yeah
[Music]
it's gonna start to be a pretty
commonplace thing to see robots
trundling around in buildings on the
streets etc and that's only gonna draw
and grow Jonathan Herst spun this
company out of his robotics research at
Oregon State University in general
people's lifestyles are going to change
and that's gonna change the way cities
flow - this is a story about how robots
will affect jobs but first we need to
understand how far artificial
intelligence and robotics have already
come warehouses and factories are being
run by robots as the lights are turned
off to save on energy costs sensors that
power autonomous movement are much
faster than ever before cars and planes
are operating by themselves robots are
doing fine detail work and responding to
our every move they're entering the
service sector displacing fast-food
workers and baristas in five to ten
years time robotics is going to
disappear from our awareness because it
is going to be what all of our smart
products have ended robots are replacing
jobs like security guards with
self-driving surveillance vehicles I
said step away from the machine
seriously hey hey we're not all the way
there this company had a few public
mishaps like this robot suicide in a
fountain I asked the CEO about it you're
never gonna learn without actually being
out in the field so the kinks are
getting worked out quickly and today
it's impossible to see such futuristic
technology without wondering about the
impact on jobs an endless array of
robots are entering our everyday lives
pair that with advances in artificial
intelligence machine learning 3d
printing and the changes are hard to
comprehend
[Music]
worldwide 800 million jobs could be
automated by 2030 in the United States
up to 73 million jobs are at risk
changes like these have taken place
throughout history like the
industrialization of Agriculture only
this time it's on a far faster timescale
Jonathan said he too has concerns about
job displacement definitely something
that can be handled well as long as
governments and policymakers are aware
of these changes that are happening and
planning for it and preparing for it you
think we're doing that I do not think
that we're doing that at present
numerous companies turned down requests
to talk about the effects Automation
will have unemployment you know you
don't want to write a banner over your
company logo we are America's top
killers correct so like that's the last
thing that you want to do and one of
America's biggest job killers may be
driverless vehicles already driving on
our roads this promo video shows
Google's subsidiary lame-o operating
self-driving vehicles on the road
without a driver to take the wheel if
something goes wrong but companies like
Google Toyota Tesla GM and uber declined
to discuss innovation or jobs even as
they greenlit the use of these
promotional videos well we're recreating
a scenario we had a pickup truck drive
along the track and actually dumped some
hay bales out of the back randomly so
we're gonna see as our car senses does a
safe lane change
since is the next one and also then
changes back the vehicles are arriving
faster than many might expect GM
announced that a vehicle without any
human controls would hit the streets in
2019 an uber placed an order for up to
24,000 self-driving Volvo's last year
the task for society with regard to car
driving uber drivers taxi drivers truck
drivers is to think about what we want
to do with people who are displaced it's
not hard to picture the uber and lyft
based gig economy is collapsing as
self-driving cars arrive everyday those
drivers are given companies the valuable
data needed to automate many in the gig
economy are unwittingly teaching
artificial intelligence how to do their
jobs three percent of the American
workforce drives for a living and that
doesn't include hotels along highways
truck stops restaurants and other
support jobs
total trucker salaries alone add up to
300 billion dollars per year so it
should come as no surprise that uber got
into the trucking business by building a
technology platform for delivering
Freight and by buying an automated truck
startup called Auto if you're a truck
driver right now and you haven't started
thinking of getting some extra training
education or so then you're in a
difficult position
so I went to meet up with some truckers
at the great American Trucking Show in
Dallas Texas trucker Brown was instantly
recognizable because of his prolific
YouTube page he does videos on
everything about trucking and that
includes automation this was an avenue
for people to go in to pull themselves
out of poverty and have a middle-class
job in an honest wage and it's there
they want it to be gone it's hard to
overstate the importance of an
entry-level middle-class job for
millions of Americans every person that
I see here it's taken care of for other
people their family every single person
you see and that shows you how much
trucking is feeding the country for
trucker Brown the profession has given
him a middle-class lifestyle where there
are few other options our first scene
automated trucks the first thing I
thought is what else could I do and I
end up being homeless a few times and
trying to trying to find my way my
granddad was a trucker my father's a
trucker
I have three brothers that are truckers
my aunts a trucker if it becomes
automated that's gone then then whatever
you know
what are the blue-collar of America
supposed to do at the truck show I met
up with Todd Spencer executive vice
president of the owner/operator
independent drivers Association for the
vast majority of the population they
really have no comprehension of just how
essential trucks and truckers are
trucking is the most common job in 29 US
states it's really difficult to think
that this is something that could be
automated very quickly or very easily
like Todd few of the truckers of the
show believe automated trucks will
arrive within the next decade anybody
who does technical backing in the docks
or driving
in inner cities automated trucks good
luck to him there's a lot of types of
places to get into so I don't think the
automatic truck can probably get into
the place nationwide it's starting to
sink in a recent poll found that 72% of
Americans expressed concerns about
robots taking their jobs when it's
cheaper to replace a worker or the robot
then eventually it'll happen
Brown drives with LaShawn Parks who also
has a YouTube channel they largely agree
on the dangers of automated trucking
everything's automated so so now you
took my above the poverty line job I say
I don't just go work at a burger joint
and that's all I made it to when the
thing is when does it stop a 2016 White
House report estimated that 1.3 to 1.7
million
truck drivers are at risk for job
automation add in taxis chauffeurs
delivery trucks and other drivers and
that number rises to 3.1 million and
even though trucker Brown and LeSean
have an idea of what's coming there's
still healthy skepticism but I don't I
don't I don't see how we can get to bad
weather and icy roads and you know
things like that I just don't see it
happening at the end of the day to me I
still believe that a driver is going to
be needed to be in that truck it's
actually a common argument for
automation letting robots do tasks that
are repetitive boring and unhealthy the
service industry is also transforming
from line cooks to baristas to servers
jobs are changing overnight
what Xoom is doing is using automation
to eliminate tasks tasks that are unsafe
tests that are boring tasks that are
repetitive and what we're doing is we're
elevating the occupation so we're
thinking about task automation versus
occupational automation
bigger brands are catching on Pizza Hut
just announced driverless delivery and
claimed that it could actually create
more jobs Julia Collins the CEO of zoom
pizza took us through some of the
efficiencies of the process and now
we're using a vision system to monitor
the path of the pizza this is a pizza
that gets our spicy sauce
Giorgio's dispenses classic sauce Martha
is our soft spreading robot this is
everyone's favorite robot so we have a
robot that never drops pizza and he
never gets burned the line is optimized
to do as many as 360 pizzas in an hour
that's really quite fast zoom Pizza is
not alone in trying to change the
industry well there are a lot of tasks
in food preparation that are highly
repetitive and low productivity so
anything that's like doing the same
thing over and over again or moving a
box around or moving a cop around a lot
of those things can be automated even
historically safe stable white-collar
jobs like doctors lawyers and bankers
are at risk there are a lot of people
who think this is all about blue-collar
work it is not we already use services
like TurboTax to replace tax advisers at
least your taxes are free Amazon's Alexa
and Apple Siri have taken on secretarial
tasks and much more hey Siri read my
schedule you have 25 appointments at
7:15 artificial intelligence is making
inroads on the legal profession
financial sector and the medical world
we need to start thinking about what's
gonna happen when large numbers of
highly-skilled and narrow skilled human
white-collar workers are displaced
medical field is huge in-service
robotics if you want to identify a key
area of growth
we'll be in the medical field that is
where everything is going mofo is a
research robot launching this year and
other robots have already made advances
in medicine some surgeries have been
transformed by robotics and I tried out
one of those machines okay how's this
work jobs in fields like medicine and
law will be just as affected by software
we can't see then robots we can techies
are in a race to replace jobs like
radiologists who spend much of their
time looking at medical scans right now
we're able to read images about 10,000
times faster than human radiologists so
you can see that we just processed 765
studies that's about two days worth of
work for a normal radiologist and we
were able to process it in about 46
seconds Kevin Lyman is lead scientist at
analytic a start-up working to redefine
the role of a radiologist deep learning
is essentially a series of algorithms
for trying almost every possible
combination and what it ultimately
arrives at is just an equation I asked
Kevin if his work could cause
radiologists to lose their jobs
AI for us is creating a lot of jobs for
radiologists and other doctors training
AI to effectively do this is an enormous
ly difficult task so today I have to go
to the doctor tomorrow there'll be
artificial intelligence software that
analyzes the information that it'll keep
track of my my you know my heart rates
my Bloods AI software wonder hundreds of
millions of people so it will have much
more better much better knowledge than
our doctor to do this is all happening
faster than expected and many of these
techie dreams are already within sight
I've got a I've got a four-year-old kid
and then a nine month old kid and the
things that I know about their future
they're never gonna learn how to drive a
car when people worry about cars being
hacked or driving into people they often
forget the daily toll that could be
avoided the World Health Organization
estimates that 1.2
five million people die each year in
traffic accidents in the United States
that number is 34,000 I don't want a
human driving my car or flying the plane
because humans are infallible and don't
learn as fast as technology so 10 15
years from now rather than having
servants and maids and chauffeurs we'll
have robots serving us before we arrive
at the utopian world of the Jetsons the
shift is likely to be a bit more
dystopian so now what happens to the
people what happens to the tech to the
uber drivers what happens to truck
drivers what happens to the entire
support system around these people it
begins to vanish over another five year
period we're going to wipe out millions
of jobs in the United States and you
know tens of millions of jobs in the
developing world what happens to those
people hey I'm Joe thanks for watching
part one I hope you'll stick around for
part two where I talk about how
automation will affect cities and don't
forget to like share and subscribe